THANK YOU.
>> Laura: WE'VE GOT A LOT TO
GET TO, I'M LAUREN INGRAM AND
THIS IS "THE INGRAHAM ANGLE"
FROM WASHINGTON TONIGHT.
THEY DEI AND THE BULLIES, THE
FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S "ANGLE."
EVERY TIME YOU HEAR SOME
EDUCATOR OR CORPORATE FLACK
REFERENCE THE IMPORTANT EFFORTS
TO PROMOTE DIVERSITY, EQUITY,
INCLUSION.
SCAM.
THE GROUPING OF INNOCUOUS TERMS
HAS BECOME ITS OWN EXCELLENCE
ACROSS THE LANDSCAPE.
THE ACRONYM IS DEI BUT IT'S MORE
LIKE BUREAUCRACY, VICTIM I'LL
LET OF, INCOMPETENCE.
CORPORATIONS SPEND AS MUCH AS A
BILLION DOLLARS PER YEAR FOR DEI
COMPLIANCE BEING PAID A HEFTY
SUMS TO OVERSEE THE WOKE
TRAINING AND COMPLIANCE.
BUT THEY DEI IS ITS OWN COTTAGE
INDUSTRY WITH ITS OWN SIDE
HUSTLES.
EVEN THE REIGNING INDUSTRY HAS
ALL THE BUREAUCRATIC DIVERSITY
LINGO DOWN PAT.
>> WE ARE INTEGRATING DER INTO
EVERY PROGRAM.
THEY ARE BEING IMPLEMENTED AND
DEPLOYED GLOBALLY.
>> Laura: GLOBALLY.
FOR THE EFFORTS TO ADOPT
QUASI-QUOTA PROGRAMS AND HIRING,
THEY GET A GOLD STAR FROM
ANOTHER DEI FRONT GROUP.
>> DIVERSITY INC. NAMED US AS A
TOP 50 COMPANIES FOR DIVERSITY
AND RANKED US AS A TOP THREE
LGBTQ COMPANY.
>> Laura: OF COURSE, IF IT'S A
STUPID IDEA YOU CAN BET THE NEA
HAS BEEN PROMOTING IT FOR YEARS.
>> IT'S IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND
THAT NOT ALL OF OUR -- ARE AS
INNOCUOUS AS PEANUT BUTTER AND
JELLY.
THEY SHAPE THE LANGUAGE WE USE
IN THE WAY WE INTERACT WITH
OTHERS BASED ON RACE, ETHNICITY,
GENDER IDENTITY,
SEXUAL ORIENTATION, AND OTHER
CULTURAL IDENTITIES.
>> Laura: TRANSLATION, YOU MAY
NOT THINK SO, BUT YOU'RE A
ROTTEN RACIST ESPECIALLY IF
YOU'RE NOT A MINORITY.
>> THIS CYCLE OF SOCIALIZATION
CAN LEAD TO MICRO-AGGRESSIONS,
STEREOTYPES, DISCRIMINATION, AND
EVEN VIOLENCE.
THESE UNINTENDED SENTIMENTS THAT
ARE EMBEDDED WITHIN THE CYCLE OF
SOCIALIZATION ARE BUILT AROUND A
CULTURE OF WHITE SUPREMACY THAT
WE MUST CONTINUALLY ACKNOWLEDGE.
>> Laura: THE NEA.
REMEMBER, THESE ARE THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE ORGANIZING THE TEACHERS
WHO TEACH OUR KIDS.
THESE TYPE OF CREEPY PROPAGANDA
STYLE VIDEOS, THEY'RE ALL OVER
THE INTERNET IT'S PAINFUL TO
WATCH BUT I HAD TO DO IT.
IT'S WRAPPED UP WITH THE
ANTIRACISM AND THE ALLYSHIP
MOVEMENTS.
IT'S A BUNCH OF CORROSIVE TRAP
AND IS NOT JUST FOUND IN THE
EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS BUT IT
EMBEDDED ITSELF INTO ALL ASPECTS
OF CORPORATE LIFE.
TRAINING VIDEOS, SEMINARS.
I LIKE THIS ONE, IT BUILDS
ITSELF AS AN UNCONSCIOUS BIAS
WORKSHOP VIA ZOOM.
ARE YOU LOOKING TO START OR
CONTINUE THE DEI LEARNING
JOURNEY?
IT'S ONLY A MATTER OF TIME
BEFORE IT SEEPED INTO THE
PRACTICE OF MEDICINE TOO.
GROWN MEN AND WOMEN REAL MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS PROSTRATE
THEMSELVES BEFORE THE DEI MAFIA.
>> CAN YOU HELP US UNDERSTAND
THIS IMPLICIT BIAS HE SAW?
I'M A DOCTOR, PATIENT COMES IN.
WHITE, AFRICAN AMERICAN, WHAT
HAPPENS IN A WAY CONSCIOUS OR
UNCONSCIOUS IN THE INTERACTION
THAT BECOMES A GENERATION OF THE
INEQUITY.
>> THEY FIND THAT OVER 70% OF
ALL AMERICANS HAVE AN ANTI-BLACK
BIAS.
>> Laura: MEDICAL SCHOOLS AND
HOSPITALS ARE ON BOARD AS WELL.
IT'S ALL BASED ON THE FAKE SIGNS
YOU REFERENCE ON IMPLICIT BIAS.
AS THEY MANIPULATED THE SCIENCE
ON COVID, GROUPTHINK ON VACCINES
AND MASKS, THEY ARE DOING THE
SAME HERE.
SO, DEI BECOMES A RELIGION LIKE
CLIMATE CHANGE.
YOU MUST BELIEVE NO QUESTIONS
ASKED, NO DOUBT BEEN TOLERATED.
IT SHOULD BE OBVIOUS WHY BIDEN
AND HIS CABINET HAVE REPEATED
THE MANTRA SO OFTEN THAT AMERICA
IS SYSTEMICALLY RACIST.
THEY ARE LAYING THE GROUNDWORK
FOR COMPLETE DEI TRANSFORMATION
OF EVERY ASPECT OF THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT AND AMERICAN LIFE.
FROM DAY ONE, I REMEMBERED THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAS
EMPHASIZED THEY ARE OWN HIRING
IS BASED NOT ON MERIT OR TALENT,
BUT ON FIRST.
>> BUILD A GOVERNMENT THAT LOOKS
LIKE AMERICA, INCLUDING THE MOST
DIVERSE CABINET EVER ASSEMBLED.
TO SPEAK OF THE MOST DIVERSE
ADMINISTRATION
IN THE HISTORY OF OUR COUNTRY.
IF I SHOULD NO, WE HAVE
APPOINTED THE MOST LATINO
LEADERS EVER TO THE CABINET
LEVEL POSITIONS.
>> Laura: YOU GOT
PETE BUTTIGIEG, TRANSPORTATION,
ALEJANDRA MALLORCA, JAVIER
MASARU, LLOYD AUSTIN.
IT'S A LEFTIST BOX CHECKING AND
IT'S BEEN A UNMITIGATED DISASTER
FOR YOU AND I.
THE MAYOR OF SOUTH BEND,
PETE BUTTIGIEG, SOME HOW HAS THE
EXPERTISE TO THE DEPARTMENT WITH
55,000 EMPLOYEES.
BIDEN SET THE STAGE WITH A BIG
EXECUTIVE ORDER THAT PLANTED
THESE POISONOUS SEEDS.
HIGHEST MITIGATION TRAININGS AT
THE ENERGY DEPARTMENT.
THEY PUSHED AND OPPRESSION
NARRATIVE AT THE
STATE DEPARTMENT.
AND OF COURSE, MAYOR PETE ON
D.O.T. EVEN CALLED DEI CRITICAL
IN ADVANCING THE DEPARTMENTS
MISSION.
MY FRIENDS, SO MUCH AS BREAKING
DOWN AROUND US AND IT'S NOT JUST
BECAUSE OF THE SUPPLY CHAIN.
BUT IT'S THE BIDEN TEAM WE KNOW
DOESN'T CARE.
IN THE END, THEY HOPE TO TRAIN A
NEW GENERATION TO BELIEVE THAT
THIS IS THE ACCEPTABLE WAY OF
ORGANIZING SOCIETY.
WE KNOW IT'S NOT.
THE ENTIRE POINT OF THE CIVIL
RIGHTS MOVEMENT WAS TO PROMOTE
EQUAL OPPORTUNITY WITHOUT REGARD
TO RACE OR ETHNICITY COME UP THE
DEMOCRATS INSTEAD ARE RETURNING
TO OLD IDEAS OF RACIAL AND
GENDER DETERMINATION BUT CALLING
IT BY DIFFERENT NAME.
SPEAK OF THE IMMEDIATE FEELING
YOU GET OR THE THOUGHTS YOU HAVE
ABOUT A PERSON AND THE
ASSUMPTION -- ANYTHING YOU FEEL
REALLY EXTEND SOMEWHERE FROM AN
EXPERIENCE YOU HAD OR YOUR
UPBRINGING.
>> DEPENDS ON THE REGION YOU'RE
FROM, THE COUNTRY YOU'RE FROM,
THE BACKGROUND YOU GREW UP IN.
THAT SHAPES THE PERSON'S
UNCONSCIOUS BIAS.
IT'S BECAUSE THERE'S A LOT OF
OPPORTUNITIES TO PROMOTE PEOPLE
WITHIN THE WORKPLACE.
PEOPLE ASSUME A WOMAN IS OF A
CERTAIN AGE WHERE THEY ARE
MARRIED AND SHE'S GOING TO HAVE
DON'T WANT TO HAVE KIDS.
>> Laura: HERE'S MY
PREDICTION.
COMPANIES THAT EMPLOY THESE
METHODS ARE GOING TO LOSE MARKET
SHARE, THEY ARE GOING TO LOSE
SALES, THEY'RE GOING TO LOSE
CUSTOMERS TO COMPANIES THAT
PROMOTE PEOPLE AND THEY HIRE
PEOPLE ON THE BASIS OF MERIT.
STATE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WITH
DEI WILL LOSE BUSINESSES AND
THEY'LL FLEE TO STATES THAT
RESIST THE DISCRIMINATION.
HOSPITALS THAT IMPLEMENTS THE
RACIST HIGHER REPROGRAMS WILL
END UP DELIVERING CARE THAT IS
SUBPAR.
LET'S PUT IT THIS WAY.
DO YOU WANT TO TAKE YOUR SICK
CHILD TO A DOCTOR WHO LANDED HER
POSITION THROUGH A DEI PROGRAM?
OR YOU WANT TO TAKE YOUR SICK
CHILD TO THE BEST DOCTOR YOU CAN
FIND REGARDLESS OF DEI STATUS?
THE MIDTERMS ARE AROUND THE
CORNER.
IN A TIME WHERE OUR COUNTRIES IN
SUCH DIRE SHAPE, WE NEED THE
BEST AVAILABLE PEOPLE IN ALL
CRITICAL JOBS.
IT'S TIME TO REJECT CANDIDATES
WHO BELIEVE IN GOVERNANCE
THROUGH WOKE DISCRIMINATION, THE
SAME PEOPLE WHO STOKE ANIMOSITY
AND ACRIMONY AMONG AMERICANS.
IT'S TIME TO DEF